آنا ما يوجد في جيوبك لأن
تلك الديوك الرومية تريد حقًا الحصول على
كل ما في جيبك ،
هل هناك بعض الطعام هناك هذه
الديوك الرومية
هذه الديوك الرومية ممتعة
جدًا فهي صاخبة جدًا إذا كنت تصفق ،
أعني من بعض النواحي أنهم جمهور رائع
لكنهم كذلك  منزعج تمامًا
جولتك من التصفيق الذي كان
رائعًا قد أقترحه ، وقد كنت أستخدم
googling للتو ، ها
أنت ذا ، أقترح عليك إضافة tryptophobia
إلى سيرتك الذاتية في المستقبل والتي أعتقد
أنها خوف من الديوك الرومية
وأعتقد أنني أقوم بتطوير الروح  من
الديوك الرومية الآن ، شكرًا لجوليا على
جولة أخرى من التصفيق من فضلك من أجل آنا
ستيوارت الرائعة
في مزرعة للديك الرومي في إسيكس ،
شكرًا لك حظًا سعيدًا لقد أسقطت ifp الخاص بي